[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui une réconciliation
qui pourrait avoir de grandes
conséquences géopolitiques
c'est celle qui se profile entre le
qatar d'un côté et les quatre pays
arabes qui l'ont boycotté pendant plus
de trois ans de l'autre ce sont l'arabie
saoudite les émirats arabes unis le
royaume de bahreïn et l'egypte mais
réussiront-ils à tourner une nouvelle
page dans leurs relations
le 5 janvier dernier l'arabie saoudite
et ses alliés annonce la fin du blocus
contre le qatar les frontières s'ouvrent
et le commerce reprend pourtant les
émirats arabes unis et bahreïn ne se
presse pas de rétablir les relations
diplomatiques avec des amitiés avec les
rangs présence militaire tueur au qatar
le soutien aux supposés du qatar des
frères musulmans du hamas et du
hezbollah
les autorités qataries déclare ne pas
vouloir changer de ligne politique
en revanche la diplomatie qatarie se dit
prête à jouer le rôle de médiateur entre
l'iran et les états unis
cette détente entre le quatuor arabe et
doit fait aussi bouger les lignes
ailleurs dans la région l'egypte fait
les premiers pas envers le gouvernement
de fayez al sa rage soutenu par le qatar
des changements pourraient avoir lieu
aussi dans le conflit et mini tour le
qatar et les émirats arabes unis
soutiennent des camps opposés
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur l'ultimatum avancée par
le quatuor arabe au qatar qui était à
l'origine de la crise c'est le blitz
après avoir rompu les relations
diplomatiques avec d'orange ou en 2017
l'arabie saoudite les émirats arabes
unis bahreïn et l'egypte présente 13
exigences au qatar parmi elles figurent
la réduction au minimum de la
coopération avec les rangs et la
fermeture de la base militaire turque au
kata accusant doha de financer le
terrorisme le quatuor arabes exigent que
leucate a rompu tous les liens avec les
organisations comme les frères musulmans
le hezbollah ou le hamas
il est en outre demandé de remettre les
terroristes et personnes recherchés par
l'arabie saoudite les émirats arabes
unis l'egypte et bahreïn à leur pays
d'origine et surtout de cesser de leur
accorder la nationalité qatarie côté
médiatique
l'exigence principale est de fermer la
chaîne d'information al jazeera et un
certain nombre de sites d'information
côté économique le qatar devrait payer
des réparations causée par sa politique
et plus encore autorisé des audits
externes régulier dernière exigence
l'alignement complet de doha dans les
domaines militaires politiques sociales
et économiques sur les quatre états
arabes entre le qatar et le quatuor
arabe la réconciliation semble bel et
bien démarré ouverture des frontières
rétablissement du commerce et du
tourisme
pourtant les émirats arabes unis et
bahreïn juge qu'il est encore trop tôt
pour parler de reprise des relations
diplomatiques avec doigts car les
désaccords restent nombreux
la situation se complexifie avec
l'arrivée de la nouvelle administration
américaine qui entend alléger la
pression sur téhéran
le kata en profite pour s'imposer en
tant que médiateur entre l'iran et les
etats-unis dans l'antagonisme entre ryad
et ankara doit propose aussi sa
médiation
on voit de réconciliation avec le qatar
l'egypte change de ton à l'égard du
gouvernement libyen d'union nationale de
fayez al sa rage les lignes commencent
aussi à bouger sur la question
palestinienne après sa visite au qatar
le hamas accepte de participer aux
premières élections au général depuis
quinze ans au yémen
abou dhabi elle doit soutiennent des
camps adverses ce qui nourrit les
tensions les situations ne pourrait
peut-être changer dans un avenir proche
alors comment cette réconciliation
va-t-elle reconfigurer le rapport de
forces dans la région
qu'est ce qui a poussé le quatuor arabe
vers la détente avec le qatar enfin
quels sont les risques qui planent sur
cet accord pour répondre à toutes ces
questions nous rejoignons pascal le
pautremat docteur en histoire
contemporaine et géopoliticien monsieur
le pautremat bonjour bonjour
tout d'abord quelle est la raison
principale de cette réconciliation selon
vous écouter pour répondre à ces
brièvement je pense que le blocus qui a
pu être mis en place contre le qatar
s'est avéré contre-productif selon
l'arabie saoudite les émirats arabes
unis et bahreïn lors idée c'était
finalement de faire en sorte que le
qatar ne sera pas rapproche pas trop de
la turquie et l'iran et force est de
constater que la ctd fait inverse donc
vraisemblablement c'est la raison
première pour laquelle ils ont ils se
sont dit qu'il fallait normaliser les
relations pour faire en sorte que donc
ce conseil de coopération des états du
golfe puisse économiquement se ressouder
mais le problème de fond demeure
les griefs envers le qatar étaient les
mêmes de la part de l'arabie saoudite et
des émirats arabes unis pourquoi alors
ryad a hanté retire complètement la
hache de guerre mais pas abu dhabi alors
voilà ça c'est le c'est le paradoxe mais
il faut bien comprendre aussi que les
émirats arabes unis sont depuis quand
même quelques années arc bouté sur les
menaces jihadistes ou les actions des
frères musulmans qui s'opère on sait
notamment en libye depuis assez
longtemps et on sait combien
finalement les émirats arabes unis sont
très très remontés et très hostile à
toute menace en fait du fondamentalisme
musulman qui peut conduire un caractère
un peu jihadistes
en automne en l'occurrence toutes les
dynamiques salafistes et c'est le qatar
qui depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années
témoignait de mécènes qui en son sein
financé soutenait les logiques
djihadiste salafiste et donc pour les
émirats arabes unis si vous voulez c'est
inconcevable de de passer l'épongé sur
ce vrai problème de fond même si
évidemment il ya cette volonté globale
d'accepter encore une fois de de renouer
le dialogue sur un socle économique sans
doute aussi parce que les états unis
aussi les y incite
mais oui effectivement au niveau
dogmatique au niveau de la proche de
l'islam politique
les les les dissonances les divergences
demeurent
monsieur le pautremat merci beaucoup
nous allons poursuivre notre analyse
tout de suite mais nous retrouverons à
la fin de ces démissions pour plus de
détails sur la question merci encore un
sommet qui scelle la réconciliation le 5
janvier 2021
la 41ème session du conseil de
coopération du golfe démarre dans la
ville saoudienne d'al oula la rencontre
est marquée par la présence de l'émir du
qatar tamim bin hamad al thani qui
refusait d'assister aux travaux de
l'organisation depuis 2010 est il est
accueilli avec une embrassade par le
prince héritier saoudien mohamed ben
salman à l'aéroport d'al oula le
résultat de la rencontre et tout à la
hauteur des attentes les membres du
conseil ainsi que l'egypte présente
spécialement pour l'occasion
si un accord censé mettre fin à l'
isolement du qatar par le quatuor arabe
désormais nous agirons comme un système
unifié pour faire face aux défis de la
région
l'accord met complètement fin aux
désaccords avec le qatar et permet le
retour intégral des relations
diplomatiques ainsi que la restauration
du trafic aérien
le blocus est donc levé mais en retour
le qatar doit aussi faire ses preuves
selon al jazeera à doha s'engage à
arrêter toutes les poursuites
judiciaires contre le quatuor arabes
dans les institutions internationales
pour le reste les autorités qataries
adopte pourtant une position
intransigeante
il n'y a eu aucune concession d'aucun
côté la crise du conseil de coopération
du golfe était une situation perdante
pour tout le monde donc mettre fin à
cette crise sera je pense un gain pour
tout le monde
en effet des signes de détente se font
sentir avec les quatre pays arabes
ouverture des frontières rétablissement
des liens commerciaux tourisme pourtant
il serait encore trop tôt pour parler de
la fin de la crise car seuls deux pays
ont annoncé la reprise des relations
diplomatiques avec le qatar et l'arabie
saoudite et l'egypte et si ryad annonce
la fin des désaccords avec doit le caire
n'est pas si optimiste selon des sources
au sein des services égyptiens de
renseignements cité par reuters
l'egypte reconnaît l'existence d'un
certain nombre de questions en suspens
dans les relations bilatérales dont le
conflit libyen et l'activité des frères
musulmans une série de rencontres
seraient organisées afin de discuter de
tous ces sujets parmi ceux qui refusent
pour l'instant de reprendre les
relations diplomatiques avec le qatar
figurent les émirats arabes unis
la position d'abou dhabi s'explique par
plusieurs raisons d'abord les relations
étroites entre le qatar et l'iran
ce dernier est vu par les émirats comme
la principale menace pour la sécurité
régionale
l'autre sujet qui fâche concerne le
soutien présumé du qatar aux frères
musulmans groupe radical considérée
comme terroriste par abou dhabi
la chaîne de télévision qatarie al
jazeera à jette de l'huile sur le feu en
poursuivant sa campagne médiatique
visant les émirats arabes unis et alors
les deux rivaux régionaux le qatar et
les émirats arabes unis pourront-ils
surmonter leurs divergences
sachant que le prince héritier d'abou
dhabi mohammed ben zayed fait du qatar
une affaire personnelle
une information fui sur wikileaks selon
le site le chef émirati aurait encouragé
ses alliés de prendre une position dure
à l'égard de doha lors de négociations à
huis clos au début des années 2000
il aurait même
opposés aux américains de bombarder le
siège de la chaîne qatarie al djazira
toujours selon wikileaks
mohamed ben zayed aurait dénoncé
l'impact négatif de ce média qatari pour
sa famille le baril lui ne se hâte pas
non plus de rétablir les relations avec
doit l'amitié avec l'iran et le soutien
présumé des frères musulmans les sujets
qui fâchent sont presque les mêmes
il existe pourtant entre les deux un
autre obstacle de taille ce sont les
tensions territoriales ces derniers mois
plusieurs incidents ont lieu en mer
ainsi que dans l'espace aérien
le qatar intercepte plusieurs bateaux
bahreïni qui l'accusent de pêcher dans
ses eaux et dénonce une violation de son
territoire souverain par certains avion
militaire de bahreïn le qatar d'un
formulées après le sommet d'al oula
aucune initiative pour résoudre les
problèmes en suspens avec bahreïn alors
comment la corde al oula petit changer
le paysage géopolitique de la région
comment les alliés qatari réagi style à
la réconciliation entre doha et les
quatre pays arabes enfin quels sont les
facteurs qui ont permis de préparer la
levée du blocus
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
après plus de trois ans de crise dans le
golfe le qatar et quatre autres pays'
arables près le chemin de la
réconciliation pourtant va-t-on aboutir
à une normalisation complète des
relations
compte tenu du fait que le qatar
entendent poursuivre sa ligne politique
malgré les pas diplomatiques qui ont été
faits dans sa direction
le 5 juin 2017 l'arabie saoudite les
émirats arabes unis bahreïn et l'egypte
rompent leurs relations diplomatiques
avec le qatar et lui impose un blocus
terrestre aérien et maritime
c'est le début de la crise diplomatique
dans le golfe persique qui couvait
depuis plusieurs années en mai 2010 est
une dernière goutte fait déborder le
vase
l' agence de presse qatar news agency
diffuse un communiqué attribué à l'émir
du qatar dans lequel ce dernier dénonce
une diabolisation de l'iran du hamas
palestiniens et du hezbollah libanais
les autorités qataries réagissent
immédiatement en dénonçant un piratage
d'informations et en démentant le
contenu du communiqué cependant le coup
et déjà porté le 22 juin
le quatuor arabe avance un ultimatum de
13 points au qatar il comprend entre
autres la réduction de la coopération
avec l'iran
la fermeture de la base militaires turcs
situés sur son territoire et enfin la
rupture définitive avec des
organisations comme les frères musulmans
le hamas le hezbollah que le quatuor
considèrent comme terroriste
le qatar répond pas un an ferme jugeant
cette demande irréaliste et cela malgré
d'énormes difficultés que représente le
blocus
le qatar importe environ 90 % de sa
consommation en produits alimentaires
dont la majeure partie passe par la
frontière saoudienne
pourtant dow a réussi à éviter
l'étranglement grâce à l'aide de ses
deux partenaires dans la région la
turquie et l'iran qui lui envoient des
milliers de tonnes de denrées
alimentaires et de l'eau par avions ou
navires et ceci dès les premiers jours
du blocus
en réponse le qatar apporte son appui à
téhéran après le retour des sanctions
américaines en 2018 en novembre 2020
une nouvelle étape est franchie dans les
relations bilatérales les deux états
signent un accord de coopération dans
les domaines de l'économie de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche scientifique et technologique
en coopérant avec téhéran
doha renforce aussi ses liens avec
ankara alors que la crise économique
éclate en turquie en 2018 et que la
livre turque s'effondre le qatar injecte
15 milliards de dollars dans l'économie
turque cotée énergétique doha dépassant
quelques années la russie dans les
livraisons du gaz naturel en turquie
devenant son deuxième plus grand
fournisseur d'or bleu après
l'azerbaïdjan malgré le renforcement des
relations avec ankara et téhéran
doha ne perd pas l'espoir de se
réconcilier avec le quatuor dès 2019 le
gouvernement qatari dit être ouvert au
dialogue sans conditions préalables avec
les quatre pays arabes
l'appel est entendu à ryad
s'ensuit une série de rencontres à huis
clos qui permettent certaines avancées
selon la diplomatie qatarie en décembre
le roi d'arabie saoudite envoie une
invitation officielle auprès de l'émir
du qatar pour participer au 40e sommet
du conseil de coopération du golfe
après un court suspense al thani nomme
finalement le premier ministre pour
participer à la rencontre
cependant ryad et ses alliés exigent une
nouvelle fois du qatar d'accepter
l'ultimatum avancées au début de la
crise c'est ici qu'un autre acteur entre
en jeu les états unis au début favorable
à la ligne dure à l'égard de doha
l'administration américaine prend par la
suite une position médiane appelons à
l'unité des pays du golfe et washington
ne cache pas ses intentions
il s'agit avant tout de la nécessité de
contrer l'influencé de l'iran
début décembre 2020 le conseiller gendre
de donald trump
jared kushner mène séparément des
négociations d'abord avec l'arabie
saoudite puis avec le qatar fin décembre
2020 le roi invite une nouvelle fois
l'émir du qatar a participé au conseil
de coopération du golfe le koweït autre
médiateur dans la crise déclare que
l'arabie saoudite est prête à mettre fin
à l'embargo
cette fois l'émir du qatar se rend au
sommet qui marque la fin de la crise du
golfe les rangs et la raison pour
laquelle le dégel en tout cas côté
arabie saoudite doit se produire
maintenant
aujourd'hui nous avons surtout besoin
d'unir nos efforts pour faire face aux
menaces qui nous entoure et surtout à
celle qui émane du programme nucléaire
du régime iranien de son programme
balistique et de ses projets de sabotage
et de destructions or pour le qatar
l'iran est un allié clef c'est un de ses
plus grands partenaires commerciaux et
sido a survécu au blocus c'est surtout
grâce à téhéran quand ryad et ses alliés
coupe les vivres au qatar en 2010 est
lié rang lui vient immédiatement en aide
nourriture aux médicaments téhéran est
là pour porter secours
les rangs ouvre aussi son espace aérien
aux vols qatari panier des cieux
saoudien et émirati
cependant l'iran n'est pas le seul à
être aux côtés de doha la turquie
accroît aussi ses livraisons
alimentaires et augmente sa présence
militaire au qatar
et dans le même temps la turquie et
l'iran sont deux principaux rivaux
régionaux de l'arabie saoudite le qatar
va t'il aussi leur tourner le dos après
la réconciliation avec ryad en fait pas
du tout les relations bilatérales sont
motivés par la décision souveraine du
pays et par l'intérêt national
du coup il n'y aura aucun effet sur
notre relation avec un pays quelconque
la question est de savoir pourquoi les
pays du golfe qui considère l'iran comme
une menace décident de rouvrir le
dialogue avec l'allié de terrain
on va essayer d'y répondre à peine
quinze jours après la fin du blocus le
kata appelle les pays du golfe à ouvrir
le dialogue avec les rangs et pour ce
faire il se propose en tant que
médiateur iran etats unis turquie arabie
saoudite
là aussi le qatar est prêt à jouer le
rôle d'arbitré
le kata assure que les pays du golfe
sont eux aussi ouverts à ce dialogue
la seule déclaration dans ce sens vient
des émirats arabes unis abu dhabi se dit
prêt à négocier avec la turquie
quant à l'iran le golf garde le silence
pour l'instant il faut savoir que le
plus grand partisan de la confrontation
avec les rangs vient de quitter la
maison blanche joe biden l'a déjà dit
pendant la course électorale face à
l'iran ils préfèrent négocier le
démocrate promet de raviver l'accord
nucléaire de 2015 est de mettre fin à la
pression maximale sur téhéran
première preuve de cette volonté buydens
hommes aux postes de vice secrétaire
d'état
l'une des négociatrices de l'accord
nucléaire iranien wendy sherman la
sortie possible de l'isolément se
profile donc pour tes ans
peut-on s'attendre à d'autres grands
changements au moyen-orient après la
réconciliation qatar aux arabes
en effet les lignes commencent à bouger
au moyen-orient le 10 janvier l'émir du
qatar accueille la délégation du hamas
mouvement islamique palestinien qui a
l'autorité politique dans la bande de
gaza à l'issue de sa visite le hamas
obtient le renouveau de subventions
qatari pour un an au lieu de six mois et
ce sont désormais 30 millions de dollars
monde
ul au lieu des 25 cinq jours plus tard
le dirigeant palestinien mahmoud abbas
annonce une percée inédite son
gouvernement et le hamas se met
finalement d'accord pour tenir en 2021
les premières élections générales
palestiniennes depuis 15 ans le qatar se
distille de nouveau au rang de principal
médiateur en palestine
si oui il devra marcher sur les talons
de l'egypte car ces derniers mois le
quai a multiplié les efforts pour
devenir la principale plate forme de
réconciliation palestinienne se met
visite diplomatique
cependant les deux pays ont déjà montré
qu'ils étaient prêts à mettre de côté
leurs différends c'est ce qu'on voit
maintenant en libye
la badoit et le caire soutiennent deux
factions rivales
le qatar a appuyé le gouvernement de
fayez al sa rage à tripoli et l'egypte
se range derrière le maréchal khalifa
haftar et son armée nationale libyenne
or après les tensions fortes cet été le
caire se montre plus réconciliant envers
elle sa rage
fin décembre une haute délégation
égyptienne seront en visite à tripoli et
rencontrer les responsables du
gouvernement
dale sa rage une première après sept ans
de rupture de relations
ainsi pour fayez al sa rage la
réconciliation dans le golfe est un
signe de plus que le processus de paix
les biens est sur la bonne voie
le chef du conseil présidentiel du
gouvernement d'union nationale salue
l'issue du sommet du conseil de
coopération du golfe en arabie saoudite
qui est parvenu à adoucir l'atmosphère
et à renforcer des liens fraternels dans
la région du golfe de façon à consolider
la solidarité arabe
et pourtant l'egypte n'est pas le seul
acteur à s'opposer au qatar en libye les
émirats arabes unis occupent aussi la
même position
de plus abu dhabi et doha s'affrontent
indirectement au yémen où il appuie les
parties rivales la fin du blocus se
va-t-elle donc apaiser les tensions dans
la guerre yéménite pour y voir plus
clair
nous revenons vers pascal le pautremat
docteur en histoire contemporaine et
géopoliticien mais sur le poteau mais le
qatar affirme qu'il n'y aura pas de
concession de sa part est ce vrai selon
vous non un manque ablement il y en a et
le je dirais le cher en témoigne mais
évidemment il s'agit aussi de ne pas se
retrouver en porte à faux par rapport
aux rigoristes 1 au socle le
traditionnaliste et conservateurs dans
le pays donc oui de toute façon il va
infléchir sa position à l'égard des
réseaux jihadistes vraisemblablement il
demandera à sa chaîne al jazeera d'avoir
une démarche un peu plus mesuré sur un
certain nombre de paramètres
est ce que pour autant il va céder aux
exigences qui lui avaient été demandés
fixé en 2017 à savoir à rompre les
relations avec l'iran prendre ses
distances avec le ramasse avec le
hezbollah
assurément non mais peut-être que sur la
forme ça changera un petit peu mais
voyez il ya à la fois oui il va changer
sa position et peut-être dans une espèce
d'adoucissement conceptuel en matière de
communication mais sur le fond à
l'évidence il y aura toujours un
maintien de liens quand même réel avec
ses différentes
ces différents groupuscules parce que là
aussi il faut pas l'oublier
la question d'un hypothétique état
palestinien reste un sujet crucial
même si on sait que les émirats arabes
unis et israël sont dans un processus de
normalisation de leurs relations
diplomatiques et économiques mais vous
les écoutez les uns les autres les
émirati comme les qatari et saoudien
disent bien que il est hors de question
pour autant d'oublier la question enfin
la question palestinienne
donc le qatar va à oeuvrer avec beaucoup
de finesse je pense avec beaucoup de
tactique constructive parce que
effectivement il le sait il est dans une
position d'un véritable tournant
véritable tournant au niveau de la
posture au sein de du conseil de
coopération du golfe mais aussi à
l'égard de la communauté internationale
et ça on l'attend un pays où tourner le
bleu qu ça a duré un peu plus de trois
ans la réconciliation sera t elle
durable elle
et voilà et ça c'est une vraie question
sémantique face tu dirais c'est une
question initiale le vrai le vrai souk
de la réflexion sur le sujet c'est est
ce que les uns et les autres vont être
en mesure de de dialoguer de deux d'agir
en conscience pour bien mettre le point
sur les éléments cruciaux et qui les
concerne tous parce que tous sont
exposés à un enjeu majeur ce sont les
problèmes socio économiques
il faut bien comprendre que comme chez
nous comme partout dans le monde les la
nouvelle pauvreté la paupérisation des
populations le désarroi social et
économique est réelle
même dans ces pays là et je pense qu'ils
en sont intimement conscient donc il
s'agit à la fois d'un côté de
privilégiés je dirais le trésor de
guerre toute leur richesse qui repose
sur le gaz et le pétrole
mais il faut aussi qu'ils trouvent une
stratégie commune pour maintenir une
économie qui soit viable et qu'il soit
plus en fait soucieuse de l'état en fait
des classes les plus défavorisées et
notamment on le sait le qatar en
témoigne fait des efforts depuis peu
certes mais en fait vis-à-vis des
travailleurs puisque vous savez que
pratiquement 70 80 % la population est
constituée de d'étrangers et on sait ô
combien le qatar était visé pour les
dysfonctionnements en matière de
violation du droit du travail et des
lois internationales sur le travail donc
il ya des efforts qui sont faits en la
matière mais tous ces pays là savent
très bien qu'il ya eu à faire du
printemps arabe de 2011 pour lesquels il
n'y a pas eu trop de soucis chez eux
parce qu'ils ont muselé endiguer prévenu
le problème mais ils n'échapperont pas
une deuxième vague donc aujourd'hui la
crise sanitaire finalement apparaît
comme une sorte de révélateur
d'accélérateur des situations sociales
et économiques et ça je pense qu'ils en
sont intimement convaincu justement où
petit le vrai encore le qatar faut-il
s'attendre à une baisse de
tensions entre la turquie et les rangs
d'une part et les pays du golfe de
l'autre le qatar pourra-t-il être le
médiateur
oui c'est effectivement l'idée que
justement le régime veut faire valoir
c'est de dire nous nous sommes en
position justement stratégique un petit
peu une situation intermédiaire et
d'intermédiaires et donc on peut aussi
oeuvré dans un sens plus constructif
mais là on le voit bien il faudra aussi
vraisemblablement que la russie ait sa
carte à jouer dans la région peut-être
aussi d'ailleurs on le verra t-on aussi
avec la diplomatie chinoise et enfin
aussi la diplomatie européenne
je pense que voyez c'est ça qui est très
intéressant dans ce dossier qui va
évoluer et sur lequel il faut rester
très attentif et très humble en matière
de deux conclusions parcellaire parce
que ça va évoluer mais on le voit bien
c'est un dossier à la fois lié au
moyen-orient mais qui concerne en fait
une large partie de la communauté
nationale et de des pays comme encore
une fois la russie la chine les
institutions européennes
et puis les états unis merci beaucoup
pascal le pautremat je rappelle vous
êtes docteur en histoire contemporaine
géopoliticien merci encore d'avoir
apporté votre éclairage aujourd'hui dans
cette émission cette partie là n'est pas
encore terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]